yellow welcome to a new video I'll do a
15 minute game again as the foot back
cam was pretty good and ok let's um
let's go or we play d4 ok let's play
Sicilian for a change I try to get some
variety in the openings here ok let's
see if you place the open or some some
sideline yeah let's go form the night
off um and not an opening which always
so yeah I was tempted to play but I
although I played it a couple of times
but it's very hard to to keep track of
the theory in this opening so ultimately
has stuck to other things ok played
Bishop e3 well on black has a huge
choice now 'if I've e6 Knight g4 on the
Maine moose
I try try this one yeah that's a funny
move actually okay let's see what is
doing if you want soon he wants to make
a try okay okay but I don't want to I
can I can repeat once more now play
something else of course I don't want to
want to make a no set move draw it moved
through my neck commended game not sure
about the merits of this move but I
don't want to make the draw okay okay
now can I can actually think of going to
e5 so just if I drop back tuned to a 6
site some just as if I would have played
96 on f3 setup wizard III not sure if 95
really is a good move this night might
easily get kicked around I could also
capture here and then play 95 and then
Knight to c6
pretty sure that this is not exactly a
main line or something how interesting I
would have expected just there should be
three or so almost like this the Sun
looks somewhat strange to me the bishop
placement ok I'll there some some
extraordinary tricks here I could for
instance some I could take on f3 it
would be an interesting idea then d 5
Bishop takes D takes d5 Queenie five
this should be seven it's the same
interesting it's got very weak dark
squares then but damn yeah okay but
maybe this is a creative idea but not a
good idea it's just some dropped the
night back in the bishop on there for
really makes a strange impression but
okay I think I get the point never play
six and then he casts its long then d 6
would be a really a week so I'm what
other methods of development I could I
could try i could dry leaf I've I could
like play g6 / g6 he most likely will
play Bishop h6 at some pointers look so
looks bad he 5 is also not the most
desirable wolf
got a couple of holes CM it's not
terrible but also not two not great I
guess I don't have much choice here
funny aspect here is that my opponent
has got the name Richard Jones with the
German flag so Richard Jones i think is
an international or soon-to-be
international master from Wales if i'm
not mistaken so i'm somewhat strange
yeah it should be five some interesting
move play Bishop e7 I it just takes and
after long castle it's hard for me to
defend them d 60 + f6 is really an ugly
move you don't really want to play of
six out but moving the queen is also not
brilliant let's say Queen to a five it's
not exactly exactly great here this
position I just want to check quickly
okay it's got a ton of games already
it's always said to always were slightly
suspicious if this would be a new
account or something but it doesn't
doesn't seem to be okay
you had somewhat difficult here to to
develop and specially p7s always
answered by just taking into the six is
falling so maybe I need to play some
other moves first Lucy eight this also
might um allow me to okay so going for
quick queen exchange I have no one no
way to to avoid the exchange some need
to take now this is interesting it looks
nice from from optical point of you
would maybe for white I mean but maybe
it is not so so terrible
I want to get rid of this Bishop first
I would like to play 97 at some point
but it looks very an ammonia SIF I would
do this now I think it most likely has
got some some kind of draw back maybe
it's an idea to first bring the bishop
to the aid and then play 97 okay I need
to speed up a bit also spent already
lots of time
if I get the chance to play 97 and then
the night's get exchanged then I won't
have a huge problems anymore that is
sick spawn okay it's looking weak here
backward porn and so on but it's this is
very often just just an illusion because
it's it's basically impossible to win it
so it's not not such a big deal only I
need to check that there are no big
technical things happening all night to
be 6 I could play rube c6 I think if he
exchanges now well I think black should
be ok then should be should be a huge
problem
yeah i think that is often known a
misconception that players have that
this pawn on d6 and this typical
structure with pawn on d6 and n t5 this
d5 whole structure which often arises
from neither off or from resnikoff that
this pawn on d6 is something of an issue
this is almost never the case this pawn
never gets lost actually unless some
black blunders but only issue with the
structures of course is some the square
d 5 okay very interesting he just
dropped this night back so now i could
could actually play a 5 could i'm not
sure interesting if you let's say i play
a five if he retreats the night I get to
play D Phi Phi think let's say a
five-night OC to d5 and this should
should help have my position actually on
a five he might try to capture on d6
would be an interesting move se6 is also
hanging but then i can take on take on
before rook takes c6 king d 7 and the
rookie sir I feel trapped they cannot
cover it some way okay let's get going
and not lose even more time here just to
finish those are the g6 porn very rarely
as a problem in this kind of positions
as it it most most often protected by
some bishop only seven other well c 7 is
more a bottom morny 7 and and while it's
it's not pretty but it's not not a huge
issue
okay return to d5 so i get to to take
here with the middle night so a pawn
replaces on a piece on d5 and that
actually should should solve most of my
job my issues here now d6 never get will
get lost and there's no apparent problem
here okay I've got a 44 well three and
pawn majority on the King side which I
like to get rolling I guess I start with
h 52 to work against his his g4 move and
then I and then okay right age for
himself so no g5 I guess let's get
something going here it's not so easy
for him to to move his pawns here
because of the King position and the
rukon see aid note that the bishop on d8
does some useful things at dumb now just
prepared the g5 advance I didn't I
didn't see this so this is of course a
drawback of the of the bishop it because
the rooks are not connected
yeah should have phone should have
thought more about this this immediate
move maybe I should have done some
preparation first this looks um looks a
bit problematic the Bishop d7 is the
problem here that here that this
formerly rather inactive bishop suddenly
gets active on d 796 this could be it
could be a problem here okay cannot walk
into a pin with Bishop takes
hmm yeah not much choice but somehow he
didn't he didn't play Bishop d7 not sure
why he rejected this let's say I play
Bishop f5 now does he have some
brilliant move then let's say rook into
age 8 and then I could play Bishop f6 I
think yeah this a five-point might be in
problem at some point I move this bishop
then there should be six coming it could
be a problem but ok let's let's check if
this Bishop d7 Rufus is really an issue
i have also rootsy for as soon as an
active reply maybe even Brooksie for 2 h
4 so again let's let's cover h8 first
prevent the rook from from entering
if he attacks the spawn on g5 with rook
g2 this would be an interesting
interesting question what would i play
then of course i can i can cover it with
King age six but then you just at least
you can give this check on h2 and I just
need to return with the draw and while
you try to make a draw and move 60 have
to reckon with her with him just playing
for a draw okay interesting now should I
is it possible body form can i play a
form to to get a free g porn he could
answer fo of course and then I would
have G for me Bishop d for us also I
never move but I have Bishop f-16 it
shouldn't be too bad to try to try to
get get a pass porn
yeah where should I go now the
interesting question yeah I guess still
the on the eighth-ranked looks you for
something is pointless not slightly okay
let's activate this this Bishop now
yeah i just spent far too much time as
it as so often this position on would be
would be nice to to have some time here
to figure it out really the rook is
badly placed i could what about bishop
f3 and then g4 but it's hard to imagine
that i'd make some progress here without
the rook support if you get the routine
to play somewhere maybe on the DF file
need to need to speed up here down on
one third on 130 it's really important
here with this time control to find the
proper moment or two to play quicker now
shock this was nice you just dropped the
rook white resign yeah very very abrupt
end here so some the shame really it's
an interesting interesting endgame here
I thought them he would though maybe
guru calf to or something and then I
would play i'm most likely Bishop f4 or
maybe exchange and then we should
therefore i'm not so sure it's very
complicated I've got this Jeep on which
is useful but the queenside is
vulnerable there should be six or
something would easy easily when the a5
porn or Bishop c8 at some point if the
rooks I exchange could win the B porn
and so on but I've got I've got the Jeep
Jeep on and in some positions i've also
got them the possibility to quickly
activate the king it's more easy it's
easier for me to to activate my king
values for wide like to check quickly
what the compass giving just 000 he
wants to play rook f2 Bishop f4 then B
form to get free porn the best porn for
white as well yeah this is certainly an
on yeah a decent suggestion yeah yeah
shame that you dropped the rook but I
would have would have gotten enormous
time term problems I just thought a bit
too long I guess some
right yeah I'm not sure the opening will
certainly somewhat better for white but
this kind of position should be you
should be just fine for me g5 is a bad
move yeah with just it just too early
maybe it's not not a terrible mistake or
something but I should just do some more
preparation something like we should be
seven first two to get the rooks
connected and then then play for g5
actually i would i would prefer black a
bit in this position because it's easier
to get something going on the King SAT
here now it is on the queenside I've
added some it's no nope no big deal this
was premature
in this position he could have played
there for mm-hmm if I was a mistake then
he could have played there for here and
on g4 he's got Bishop d7 young yeah I
got got a bit confused him after I
opened up the position too early yeah I
found the interest on a positional
positional battle but unfortunately he
just just blended the rook okay and
thanks for watching I will only a
managed one video today as I need to run
to a meeting with my club mate so um it
was a little bit unexpected to f this
meeting so I wanted to make two or three
videos but i only managed this one so
yeah thanks for watching and i guess
i'll upload them some more tomorrow see
you then